il vient de nulle part on ne sait pas
qui il est qu'est ce qu'on sait de lui
il guide des gens désespérés
alors c'est une secte on ne sait pas
avec qui il est allié ils pourraient
réunir une arme et il pourrait bien les
conduire à leur mort
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu foutais rangs serrés
je suis aller délivrer un message
le message de qui de mon père
qui est ton père
on l'a perdu qu'est ce que vous dites
est hélas il un disparu
non on disparaît pas comme ça nous avons
tous assisté à lille
il a aussi sauvé la vie de ma fille il
faut que tu vois ça
en faire là aussi longtemps que possible
il a pas jusque là qu'est des doigts
elle s'est retrouvée le texas on l'a
aidé à mon avis
vous êtes en mouvement syrie israël
texas c'est la nature de mon travail
et qu'est ce que c'est ce travail
c'est le travail de terrain
vous qui êtes il n'avait pas vu ce que
j'ai fait et si j'avais vu ce que vous
avez vu je l'appellerai la seconde venue
jusqu'où ce nouveau mouvement se
répandre hâtif
j'ai l'intention de tout découvrir sur
vous
tout ça est plus important que vous ne
l'imaginez